[Aplausos]
sí
jackie chan angela merkel coronel
sanders
el el papá francisco manny pacquiao me
creerían si les digo que todas estas
personas tienen una sola cosa en común
que es muchísimo más fuerte que todas
sus diferencias
pero a pesar de todas las situaciones
que vivimos de ciudad a ciudad y de país
a país nos damos cuenta que a pesar de
existir esa división existe unión como
es el caso de ellos dos no seria sin
yalín también mejor conocido como nace l
dos personas que para sus países
deberían ser enemigas con con costumbres
tan diferentes y de familias tan
diferentes que no hay razón por las
cuales se tendrían que llevar un poco de
contexto acerca de ellos él es palestino
ella israelí él creció en una familia
musulmana ella en una familia judía con
tradiciones mormonas y a pesar de esto
ellos dejaron decidieron dejar de lado
esos prejuicios lo que la gente dice
actuar conforme a lo que ellos conocen
decidieron salir a viajar decidieron
salir a conocer de primera mano qué es
lo que pasa en el mundo qué es lo que
piensan los demás
y este tipo de historias nos enseñan que
a pesar de que parezca no haber una
salida de que parezca no haber hacia
dónde ir que siempre el hay siempre hay
una salida en este caso esa salida era
dejar al lado sobre la zona de confort y
salir a explorar salir a conocer las
demás culturas
nos enseñaron la importancia de salir a
viajar
por qué
les voy a contar una historia porque
todo empezó para mí
en 2011 tuve la oportunidad de vivir un
año en dinamarca y no les podré mentir
antes de irme me moría de miedo de
nervios de incertidumbre de decir que
estoy haciendo a que me voy tan lejos
pero decidir tomar todos esos
sentimientos y convertirlos en algo
bueno verles el lado positivo decide
convertirla en curiosidad en apertura al
cambio en experiencias
y en efecto fue un año lleno de
experiencias de conocimientos pero más
que nada fue un año lleno de
aprendizajes
toda la oportunidad de conocer a
personas de muchísimos países con
culturas tan diferentes que parecía
imposible encontrar algo que nos uniera
pero conforme pasaba el tiempo y más
convivíamos me empecé a dar cuenta que
no se encontraba no se trataba de
encontrar nuestras diferencias sino de
encontrar esa cosa en común que
compartíamos en este caso era la
experiencia todos estábamos fuera de
casa la mayoría miles de kilómetros
viviendo con una familia con costumbres
totalmente diferentes a las nuestras
tratando de entender una cultura que
nada que ver con la mexicana tratando de
hacer la parte de nuestra día a día y
bueno más que nada tratando de entender
un idioma que déjenme les digo era muy
complicado
y esto me llevó a pensar me llevó a que
hiciera clic en mi cabeza qué pasaría si
todos tuviéramos la oportunidad de vivir
aquello que yo estaba viviendo en ese
momento
si todos tuviéramos un amigo en cada
país podríamos así evitar los conflictos
entre países
se dice que nosotros somos la primera
generación en ser conscientes de cómo se
encuentra el mundo y que al mismo tiempo
somos la última generación que puede
hacer algo al respecto dice que esto
normalmente es más en el ámbito del
medio ambiente pero qué tal si decidimos
transformarlo y aplicarlo a romper esas
barreras que nos separan entre países
si decidimos en lugar de discriminar y
marginar a los demás darnos la
oportunidad de sentarnos escuchar y
entender su situación
y entonces así podremos dejar de lado
nuestras diferencias
seguramente todos hemos escuchado esta
frase una imagen vale más que mil
palabras
pero yo creo que cuando una palabra
tiene valor contiene mil imágenes
porque una palabra puede ser más potente
que una lluvia de misiles una palabra
dicha o no dicha grita dao susurrada
una palabra puede generar una revolución
entera
donald trump
kim jong-un vladimir putin
ustedes creen que si ellos hubieran
tenido la oportunidad si ellos hubieran
tenido la oportunidad de convivir de
jóvenes y de entender mejor sus
ideologías habría la misma fricción que
hay hoy en día
se dice que el lenguaje constituya la
realidad y veámoslo como un juego
en el cual si cambiamos las reglas del
juego entonces estaríamos cambiando el
juego es decir
si logramos escuchar lo que los demás
tienen que compartir y logramos verlos
desde otra perspectiva entonces
podríamos cambiar la realidad
y que estoy intentando aquí que se
logren dar cuenta que la barrera más
peligrosa es la que nosotros mismos
creamos
la buena noticia aquí es que también
está en nosotros derribarla
y quizás suena fácil derribar mi propia
barrera y pues en teoría lo es lo
difícil no es lo difícil es estar
preparado para estar listo para lo que
hay del otro lado
cuando yo comencé a derribar mi propia
barrera me di cuenta que entre más
conocía más desconocido y entonces caí
en una especie de vicio si así lo
queremos ver pero un vicio bueno un
abismo que me hace sentir este gusanito
de siempre querer salir a conocer más
gente a entender su forma de actuar
y este vicio me ayudó a comprender que
por ejemplo los chinos salen a bailar
alrededor de las 7 de la noche en las
calles
[Música]
pero me ayudó a darme cuenta que esto no
solamente pasa en china sino en otros
países
[Música]
y bueno para que ir no es tan lejos
bueno el punto es que cuando tienes la
oportunidad te unes a ellos y este
gusanito también me ayudó a entender por
qué los chinos se te quedan viendo y se
acercan a tomarse fotos contigo o te
toman una foto y al final entiendes que
es porque eres demasiado diferente a
ellos que realmente no están
acostumbrados a ver gente como nosotros
o me ayudó a entender que los
escandinavos no son fríos como
normalmente lo pensamos que lo único que
les hace falta es entrar en confianza
o que los holandeses a pesar de ser de
una de las culturas más abiertas y
openmind
necesitan tener todo super planeado todo
con agenda para poder tener esta cena
tuvimos que agendar la desde dos meses
antes y ni siquiera pudo haber sido en
un fin de semana
y bueno muy padres las experiencias pero
también aprendí que la cultura no sólo
se experimenta por vivencias sino por
comida
realmente probar lo que otro país tiene
para ofrecer te ayuda a conectar a
terminar este entendimiento de otra
cultura
y finalmente este gusanito me ayudó a
entender cosas que por ejemplo no todos
los argentinos toman mate o que en
ecuador tienen llamas como mascotas en
las escuelas cuando yo antes pensaba que
eso podía pasar más en perú o que los
polacos son las personas más cariñosas a
pesar de todos los acontecimientos que
han vivido
aunque los ingleses por más especiales
que parezcan están más que abiertos a
conectar contigo ya compartir contigo su
hogar
[Música]
porque no se trata de quién tiene más
likes en sus fotos quién viaja más quién
llega más lejos quién conocen más países
se trata de ser lo suficientemente
curioso de tomarse un tiempo
y admirar
contemplar
y tomarse la escoria de voltearse con la
persona que tienen junto y decirle hola
porque no necesariamente necesitamos
cruzar una frontera tomar un avión para
conocer a personas de diferentes
nacionalidades
lo único que necesitamos es romper
nuestra burbuja esa burbuja en la que
vivimos y darnos la oportunidad de ver
que hay más allá
y en cuanto a menos cuenta nos vemos
estaremos hablando con una venezolana
que conociste en el parque de tu casa o
estará recibiendo una argentina a una
chilena unas danesas un colombiano en tu
casa y estarás descubriendo tu país
junto con ellos
o incluso una argentina estará poniendo
en alto el país en tu nombre país en el
que vives
o incluso terminarás compartiendo casas
con las que ni siquiera con personas con
las que ni siquiera entiendes lo que
están diciendo
el punto aquí es lograr dejar de lado
nuestras diferencias y volvernos a
hablar con la persona que tenemos juntos
se trata de conocer
para querer
de viajar para conectar con otras
culturas entenderlas vivirlas de hablar
con los locales escuchar sus historias
compartir tus aventuras entender sus
pensamientos conocer sus diferencias y a
pesar de eso comprender que todos somos
parte de un mismo mundo
y si no me creen intenten cantar la
banda en otro país y verán lo que pasa
[Música]
ya nada
[Aplausos]
y con esto no los estoy invitando a que
dejen todo y agarren su mochila y se
vayan a viajar por el mundo a conocer
nuevas culturas nuevas personas aunque
he de admitir que lo he considerado
varias veces lo que quiero lograr es que
abras tu mente que te dejes sorprender
por todo lo que puedes aprender de lo
que los demás tienen que contar
que viva su cultura y que logres dejar
de lado sus diferencias
porque como bien dijo henry miller el
destino de uno nunca es un lugar sino
una nueva forma de ver las cosas
y con esto hoy te pregunté
estás listo para comenzar a ver a través
de unos nuevos ojos
para entender a los demás y terminar con
los conflictos entre países
porque no hay excusa para no escuchar
las historias de los demás de aprovechar
esa oportunidad de poder viajar a través
de ellas de vivir a través de ellas
porque viajar
es vivir gracias
[Aplausos]